Hello BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Do we want to try this again?
I thought we were muted.
I thought so too, that was so weird.
Why did we both think that?
I don't know.
Were we muted?
Let's try again.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, we're hiding, we're hiding, we're hiding.
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Moco-chan!
I have to sneeze!
Let's go on.
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're apparently sneezing.
I'm the jam host of FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Thank you for joining us for our 173rd episode today!
Do you sneeze that often, FUWAMOCO Morning, in the first place?
I think it's pretty rare nowadays.
Well, we'll see.
But!
For those who are joining us today for the very first time, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show
It's every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday, aka FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Right now, FUWAMOCO Morning will be brought to you temporarily on Mondays once a week.
Yeah, because Mondays is a pretty nice day.
Yeah, is it?
And that way we can get more balance.
Yeah!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you for the hashtag hashtag!
Let's do it, Moco-chan!
Let's start the day on the right paw!
Only the day, not the week.
And the week!
All the days, not the month.
Let's do our best, okay?
It was a fun weekend, right, Moco-chan?
Yeah!
There should be no bugs.
It's a Monday, but it's a new week, only possible.
Um.
What?
Wow.
Moco-chan.
I think it's been a Pero Sighting.
Pero Sighting.
Does it have to be at the beginning of every week?
It's important information, it goes at the beginning right!
Just like a band-aid.
Should it go at the end?
I don't know.
Okay.
Where was Pero sighted now then?
Let's take a look.
Yeah.
De-den!
Where?
MisDo!
Get away from those pon-de-rings, Pero!
He ate one!
What?
I mean, I guess if it was a free one, then it's okay!
Maybe.
Yeah?
If it's free, then it's pretty much just like he's eating garbage, right?
No, the same one out of the garbage can, that one's free.
Yeah, maybe.
Do you agree, Alphys?
I don't know, is anyone doing trash?
Not to me.
And you can freeze them.
You can!
But should you.
And just like that question, Pero should not be getting them.
No, that's not a question.
It's an answer.
You need to make sure that you eat lots of them and Pero gets none of them, okay?
You really want to be pretty, I don't know.
Why would you want to get Pero for me?
I'm saying if you really, really want to, I'm not suggesting anything, okay?
But they look delicious!
Enjoy them, it's okay!
BAU BAU!
Watch out for Pero!
Not for nasty Pero.
Got it.
But that's what you are for.
BAU BAU!
Well, there's a number of things that happened over this weekend.
And one of them, FUWAMOCO had a lot of fun doing.
We had a watch-a-long of all for one together with bees and bugs.
Over at the rat shed!
The first time FUWAMOCO at the rat shed together with Bae-senpai!
It was really nice!
It was both day 1 and 2 very comfy.
I got to hug Goose's son.
It was just a very nice time.
A bit silly.
You enjoyed it?
Yeah!
Ruffians!
Did you see the rats with Bae-senpai?
But you know, speaking of rants over what happened in New York, there's a lot of them there.
But Ruffians, maybe you were able to go and join us in New York at Radio City Music Hall, but you haven't been able to watch the streaming
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
There's one thing I do want to say, okay?
There was a bit of a... Not really a misunderstanding.
We don't have those anymore, Moco-chan.
A happening.
I know, I know, I know.
No more misunderstandings, but... A bit of a happening.
A happening!
Where I stretched a bit.
And my joints, they went...
And I thought maybe you could hear, especially because you said, what was that?
Was that your joint?
So, we went back and we listened to it.
I thought, if you heard that, that was a pretty good microphone, huh?
And you were saying it was crunchy before.
So, you heard well.
We went back to listen.
Yeah?
How could you think that was my joints?
It sounded like all my bones broke.
It was... It was the bag of popcorn.
It was the bag of popcorn.
Okay.
I didn't hear Moco-chan's joints crack.
I laughed so hard.
How did you think that was my joints?
I was like... Did you hear that?
I was like, no, I heard the bag crackle.
It was just perfectly timed because I bumped into the bags.
It went crinkle.
Yeah?
How did you make that?
No!
My joints don't sound like popcorn!
That would be pretty bad though!
Right!
You thought Moco-chan was dusty!
Moco-chan's not dusty!
Not like that!
No!
I would be really worried if, you know, anyone sounded like that when they stretched.
Yeah?
Okay.
Make sure you stretch Ruffians if you're a little bit crunchy like that.
We'll see a doctor.
Perhaps.
Perhaps, yeah.
Okay.
Because you might be popcorn.
Yeah.
But please go and check it out!
Again, the streaming ticket's in the archives available until September 24th at midnight ENT.
So maybe you want to see howling once more.
Or lifetime showtime on the big stage for the first time once more!
Now's your chance, Ruffians!
Don't put it off!
We put it off before and then we regret it, right?
Regret.
Yeah.
Please go, Ruffians!
You can take your screenshots, too!
I heard the Twitter headers are all the rage right now.
Maybe you can go take a screenshot and make that your header, huh?
It's not the 21st, it's by the 24th.
24th.
24th!
That's why we're telling you!
We wouldn't tell you things that were out of date now.
No.
Please remember, it's the 24th.
BAU BAU!
You already used your performance in the battle.
You're on trend, huh?
Before the trends.
Well, speaking of...
I'm not good at this.
Speaking of trendy, because... Always trendy.
Yeah!
There was a very special anniversary recently that was celebrated over the weekend!
It was hololive English's 5th anniversary!
And they celebrated it with a 3D concert!
Fortune Spinner!
On the hololive English official channel!
Yeah, we were able to watch!
Put your paws up if you watched Ruffians!
Missed a lot.
Missed the archive, you know.
Illusion Boy.
Otsume!
Now they're going on to their 6th year.
It's the 5th year!
Here comes the 6th year!
You watched it!
BAU BAU!
There was a very touching whole year medley of connect the worlds and breaking dimensions.
Bibideba was performed too!
Otonoke!
Whenever I hear Otonoke I think of Calli-senpai.
And then of course they performed their new song Fortune Spinner as well!
They also have a new music video too!
Did you look?
Did you see it?
Have you listened to it?
It's now streaming as well!
Very jazzy!
Wow, what did you think, Ruffians?
It doesn't need a streaming ticket!
No streaming ticket!
No, no, no!
It's just on the hololive English official account!
No streaming ticket.
Kiara-senpai's rock n' roll performance!
Wow!
Did you not see the ticket teasers?
I'm singing them!
Because we are talking about all for when it could be misunderstood, I am just starting to stop the misunderstandings.
That's all.
You see?
The future Moco-chan.
You need a ticket if you don't want trouble.
But maybe sometimes trouble... I don't mind giving up a cookie Moco-chan.
Trouble could be interesting.
That's all.
But we're so happy.
Yeah, please check it out, okay?
We've both missed so much and we're looking forward to continuing to have lots of fun all together with them.
All for one, maybe.
All for one!
Yeah, as hololive, yeah!
BAU BAU!
I think there's gonna be something else fun happening all together this week, too.
Oh, maybe.
Maybe.
But it's a little... It's a little weird.
BAU BAU!
Fun things?
Yeah!
What fun things?
I have a question for you.
For me?
No, not for you!
It's not me!
Is Chichi okay?
Well, it was...
Her 500,000 subscribers celebration which is her graduation!
GG!
BAU BAU!
Wait, uh... Are you okay?
Cuz, um, apparently her idea of celebrating is a bit... a bit different from ours, I'd say, maybe.
Yeah.
A little bit.
She song... song?
She... She did a lot of things.
Was she okay?
Yeah.
September.
That's 21st.
That's not now.
I don't know.
How long was it?
Crazy.
Chichi G is not crazy.
I don't know if she's okay.
Remember?
Do you remember?
Well, I... There were things that occurred.
Yeah?
We had... There was a... Hat?
What?
What's going on here?
Is that really us?
I don't know, I can't tell.
They look kinda different, Moco-chan.
What?
I can't tell.
I can't see their eyes.
Yeah.
What happened here?
And then, there's other stuff.
Oh, I don't know what's happening there.
Oh, weird.
Who knows what's happening there?
There's no archive.
Why is there no archive, Moco-chan?
Maybe there's a reason because... Who knows?
We can't see this.
It's not allowed to be seen anymore.
For reasons.
Well, I think the answer to the question you remember...
No.
I don't remember.
Nobody remembers.
I don't know.
It's September 22nd.
BAU BAU!
And the answer to it is GGOK.
We don't remember.
BAU BAU!
5pm?
What time is that?
Really?
What time is 19 o'clock?
7pm PD!
FUWAMOCO, we're having our ARRIVAL EVENT in Hoenn!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, do you know what WHOLE EARTH is?
Well, now is the perfect time to figure it out.
WHOLE EARTH is a project from cover that's been in development for a long time.
But now, it's here.
It's the next evolution in bringing whole life, whole life talents together with you in a way not possible before in a new immersive social experience.
And if you are still confused,
You know what?
FUWAMOCO's Arrival Fest is the best time to figure it out!
You can go and download Holo Earth, and then once you log in, then maybe we can all play together!
Yeah!
Because for the Arrival Festival, there's a bunch of fun stuff happening!
There's gonna be new avatar items!
And fun stuff!
Yes!
FUWAMOCO shirts just like on the TV!
The very first shirts that we released!
Ruffians!
And headbands!
Yes!
Special items!
Did you just ask them, do you remember?
You don't, cause the shirts came out a long time ago.
A lot longer than...
I'll be cute!
Thank you FUWAMOCO!
But there's gonna be lots of motif t-shirts and penlights that you can use to cheer us on.
Do you recognize them?
FUWAMOCO Beard!
Can you tell us where they're from?
Two different types too.
Yeah!
It'll be so much fun.
I can't wait to use them too.
I'm gonna cheer you on, Moco-chan.
Yeah.
Yeah!
Wow, there'll be special text plates you can use.
BAU BAU!
Yeah, so we can all chat together.
Moco-chan, what does that one say?
Hi.
Yeah!
You're gonna go get it now?
BAU BAU!
And...
These are some BAU BAU poses!
So we can pose all together!
One for each of us!
I wanna take a big group photo all together with the Ruffians!
Yes!
Like this!
Can we do it all for you?
Yes!
We pose all together!
There's also a life-size acrylic stand for decoration.
Wait, so you can go and take photos together with the FUWAMOCO here too?
I feel sort of embarrassed, I don't know.
This one is sort of embarrassing.
Moco-chan, can you pose next to me and I'll pose next to you?
Ah, true!
You can do a BAU BAU pose next to me!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
FUWAMOCO!
We might be able to play it!
Yeah!
On the event day all together!
Parkour!
Yeah!
We're really looking forward to it.
But Ruffians, if you think you're gonna get creative and make us a special course that we can get all silly and tumble all over the place.
No one will be skilled.
But make sure that you make it by
24th, not the 21st, the 24th at 8pm PT.
You did it!
You could tell what that was!
Jump out, Moco-chan!
So you only have about two days left, two and a half days left.
So if you're interested, please do it, okay?
I know you can be really creative with your feelings.
And you know how FUWAMOCO is when it comes to being nice and coordinated.
Very coordinated.
Should it be super hard?
I would say just have fun.
Be creative.
It doesn't need to be hard.
It's not gonna be hard for us.
You are very creative.
Do not put yourself down.
It's not time for the pup.
Most coordinated doggoes, thank you!
Thank you!
Yes, I'm very sorry too.
Yeah, end!
Well, there's a special bonus too.
Maybe there's some Ruffians that still don't really realize how it is free to download.
Yes, yes!
But if you log in during this period from the 22nd at 2am PT.
So, that's now.
Logging in now.
If you log in now.
Now?
Now.
Now if the calculations are correct, if you log in now, until the 28th at around 8am PT, you can receive special poppers, fireworks, and the FUWAMOCO text plays right now!
And if you log in during the event itself, you'll get 300 regular holo coins!
Now!
So please go get your paws on them and we can have a bunch of fun all together during our holo-earth arrival festival.
You know, we're really happy to be able to do this.
Right!
First holo-earth!
We get to be able to explore holo-earth all together with you.
We really wanted to figure out what it was.
BRB, okay!
We're waiting though!
But where do we download it?
If you go to holo-earth...
hololive website, you can go download it there.
hololive sync.
But you know you only get one arrival festival.
Yeah!
So here we go, Ruffians.
We can't wait to see you there!
Maybe there'll be more fun stuff too.
Maybe.
I'm sure there will be.
BAU BAU!
There's gonna be a bunch of other exciting streams this week too, but...
Moco-chan.
I don't know.
Pup Talk.
Obviously Ruffians are thinking you need a pup talk because you're already putting yourself down saying you're not creative this early in the morning.
I think the Ruffians kind of woke up on the wrong side of the bed.
Obviously.
Okay, okay.
I'll give you a pup talk.
Okay.
Ruffians!
It's that time of the week again!
I don't know how, but it's already time for a Mococo Pup Talk!
And you're gonna hear it straight from me, Mococo!
Ruffians!
You know, are there some days when you wake up and you feel, you know, funny?
Maybe...
A bit grumpy.
Maybe a bit fuzzier than other days.
Yeah.
Wow!
You know what you can do to combat it?
Fight it!
First is to understand that something is up with your heart.
Try your best!
You know, maybe call it an early night.
Oh, and when you can't do a butt.
I suggest having a kind older sister to help hold the fort down for you.
Yeah?
Got it!
It's important to lean on others when you realize you need help.
So don't forget it, okay?
Ganbatte ne!
BAU BAU!
You can count on me, Ruffians, just like Moco-chan does mine.
I didn't say that, okay?
But you know, Ruffians, just do your best.
Maybe there's somebody else really close right beside you too that you can count on as well.
You can do it, Occhi!
BAU BAU!
Wow!
Let's take a look.
Who's our Doggie of the Day today, Moco-chan?
Well, today's Doggie of the Day is... De-den!
It's Coco!
Coco BAU BAU!
She's very brave from this photo.
Not scared of any fuzzy demon dogs, huh?
Maybe she should be.
I don't know, you can see she's sitting right down on you, Moco-chan.
Swing dominance.
Maybe you'll sit down on her head!
Maybe.
Thank you.
BAU BAU!
How does Coco BAU BAU, Moco-chan?
Well, maybe like... BAU BAU!
BAU BAU!
It has a very shadowy sound to it too.
Well, we can tell.
She's a very brave and courageous doggy.
She loves to show her strength in a sassy way, you know?
Maybe it might get her in trouble.
Just, you know, make sure that she doesn't sneak up on you or you might be attacked by her warm cuddles.
That sounds like a nice thing.
BAU BAU!
Today I went on a walk.
Today's walk is... De-den!
Cute!
Such a wonderful FUWAMOCO!
Mushrooms!
Big mushrooms!
Big!
Bigger than them.
And look pretty big here too.
Those are big mushrooms.
Now you can tell how big they are, right?
Yeah!
I can smell.
Be careful with wild plants and mushrooms, okay?
Okay!
Maybe don't touch them.
We don't know, it could be poisonous.
Are you trying to say FUWAMOCO and fungus together?
No.
I do like mushrooms though.
But these are the ones that you just look at and then you go on.
And then you go to the store and buy some.
Because mushrooms are meat!
And the ones at the store are yummy.
For sure.
Don't touch these ones.
Let's make sure you have lots of fun, okay?
I hope you find more cool fall things.
Maybe turn over some rocks or logs.
Try to find what's it, what's it, what's it.
The fairy circle.
Ah, the mushroom fairy circle.
Have fun!
BAU BAU!
Yeah, some cool bugs too maybe!
And next we have our Question of the Day!
Today's Question of the Day is... De-den!
Hi FUWAMOCO!
Hello!
I'm curious on your organization levels.
Whenever you get a note on or off stream, where does it go?
Physical notes?
Text files?
Something fancier?
How many notes are there now?
Well... It all gets written in one... thing.
It's a notepad.
A text file.
And then when I don't need that note anymore, I delete it.
Yeah.
But I think I'll be- Have we saved this file?
No, it's never been saved.
I think it autosaves.
Maybe.
Probably, because I've never had a problem.
Yeah.
It's auto-saving.
And it has a bunch of ideas that we think of or anything we know that we might forget.
We just put it right there.
Yeah.
Physical notes get lost, so it's all very helpful.
I can just scroll, find it.
Yeah.
But how many notes?
I mean, it's just one note.
It scrolls infinitely.
That's a long scroll.
Near the top is the plans for the 1 million celebration merchandise sale.
First year anniversary merchandise.
None of this was first year, was it?
Happy?
Oh that didn't happen though.
I like how it says something.
It says FUWAMOCO something something brackets probably not.
And by the way, Fuwawa, I also have a notes document on my computer too.
Lifetime Showtime!
Choreo orders!
Here's some game titles.
Yeah, ideas for streams.
It's not saved.
No.
Stream titles.
More stream ideas.
What's that stream?
There's just one stream.
It's just titled...
Kitten Stream.
What was that one?
I don't know.
Donkey Kong Country 2 and then Kitten Stream.
Kitten Stream.
Hello, hi.
Here's some sort of karaoke plans.
Couple songs.
Setlist.
Probably everything where like, oh this could happen.
I think these are requests.
That's how it goes.
That's how it works, Ruffians.
And now you know.
Oh, one says... Wrestling moves.
That was probably a to-do list.
That's a good kind of things.
All this stuff.
But you know, I think maybe we should go through it, maybe delete some.
I don't think so.
Why should we need to?
No.
That's how it works.
That's what organization levels.
Just like Moco-chan's downloads folder.
It's good.
I'm more organized.
Don't delete the memories!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions!
Please send us more questions!
Doggie of the Day is okay!
I wanna see some very floofy doggies!
And you know, your vlogs are getting nice and cool.
And if tragedy occurs, please share your Pero sightings.
Just so that we can all be a FUWAMOCO.
And most importantly, do not forget to use the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Thank you, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Well, we have some streams coming up soon, Moco-chan!
Our next team!
We're gonna be playing Spelunky 2!
Together with... Autofister!
Whichever one!
We're gonna be playing F5PFT tonight!
Tonight!
So we hope that you'll join us!
Yes!
It's a game for players.
I'm pretty sure, but if it's not, then we'll be three players.
We'll figure it out.
But we're really looking forward to it.
It's a first collab.
Yeah!
So, it'll be lots of fun.
And then!
Actually!
Right after that!
We talked about it a bit in members, but we're waiting for FUWAMOCO.
We're gonna be playing...
What are you doing?
De-den!
It's gonna be releasing very soon on this one!
It's gonna be our first pre-release game ever that we're playing!
And not just that, it's gonna be our first Silent Hill game ever too!
We're really excited!
This time, Silent Hill F is written by the creator of Higurashi no Naka Korone When They Cry, Ryukishi7!
And Umioko too!
Shiori, we have to just go already.
Moco-chan, do you think we'll be okay?
We can fight, it'll be okay.
Ruffians are gonna help us.
You better.
How, Moco-chan?
They don't know.
You better help us.
I don't think they made it inside of the house.
Okay.
We'll have a bunch of fun, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
And that is all tonight.
Get ready, Ruffians!
And uh, yeah.
It'll be, maybe, a lot of fun.
BAU BAU!
And for the Ruffians joining us in the archive today, your FUWAMOCO word is... It's BAU BAU SPELUNKY HAIR!
Thank you so much Ruffians for joining us today for another FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our extra-special Ruffians today!
Zero-Secret!
BAU BAU!
Mike186.
Kento.
BAU BAU!
Nerdy Lundy.
Rikochino.
BAU BAU!
Tom.
Ichiro.
BAU BAU!
Victor.
Brendan.
BAU BAU!
Pogaru!
Moco-chan, how are you?
Demon.
Mococo.
BAU BAU!
Morning!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!